at protecting and promoting the rights
of the child we consider here in this
house and in the commission the legal
obligation but not only that also the
moral imperative and you rightly said
many times that this is a good reason
for celebration but that we have to
continue working on better
implementation not only of the
convention but also of the related
legislation which should guarantee the
protection of rights of the children
there is also an economic case because
according to many studies according to
many papers we work with it is also one
of the most valuable long-term
investments our economies and societies
can make children who are disadvantaged
are less likely than they're better off
Spears to do well in school enjoy good
health and realize their full potential
later in life the cost of responding to
this in the future is much higher than
investing in children's well-being today
promoting and the protection of the
rights of all children is at the core of
our obligations let's continue to work
together to make the ambitious
principles of the United Nations
Convention on the Rights of the Child a
reality for all children in Europe and
in the world thank you very much finding
for commissar in Juba
absolute behave in ominous cards is for
ministering to poor item check at her
positon des members of the Parliament
the UN Convention on the Rights of the
Child is undoubtedly contributed to the
improvement of the lives of children
across the globe and the progress
achieved needs to be celebrated I thank
you for this very timely debate it shows
the commitment of the European
Parliament the 30th anniversary of the
convention is an opportunity to
celebrate our common
achievements however a lot remains to be
done
investing in children throughout their
journey to adulthood is not only a moral
duty but also an essential investment in
a better future for all of humanity and
mr. president as we are celebrating the
30th anniversary of the UN Convention
one has to bear in mind that the world
has indeed changed it is very different
that 30 years ago
for instance we had no internet then and
that it's a new environment for our
children they are living in a despite
its possibilities for instance in
tackling loneliness or enabling online
education environments it may also cause
harmful addiction or as MEP macchina
rightly said it may increase the risk of
sexual exploitation by ruthless
predators or provide a platform on
online bullying we do enhance the
isolation but we have to take this new
challenge also into account and it's not
only as parents who shall address this
challenge but also the EU its
institutions and the member states as a
poem says for a child you cannot say
tomorrow
his name is today thank you very much
for this debate
finding feminist win to polenin the
auspice this wasn't the optional feature
on